ils guettent l'ennemi prêt à tirer ses
soldats ukrainiens sont déployés sur une
position stratégique de kiev la nuit va
bientôt tomber des troupes russes pour
est arrivé et des reds aérien frappé la
capitale
nationale ballet
nautique combatif et à 120% on est prêts
à défendre notre pays d'accord on va pas
mais jamais
les huit dernières années larifou
chrétienne a appris comment terme battre
ce cruel
de
sa mère
on a élu notre président nous les
ukrainiens auraient choisi de nous mêmes
at il ajouté qu'il va venir est
renversée il
nous plaît
on a grandi pour ne pas avoir peur on
n'a pas d'autre choix que de défendre
on doit vaincre pour les prochaines
générations d'enfants et craignent pour
leurs futures et pour leur liberté
dans les rues de kiev des barrages
improvisés
les autorités ont appelé la population à
s'armer et à préparer des cocktails
molotov pendant la journée les
détonations une nouvelle fois
authentique et depuis ce samedi 17
heures et jusqu'à lundi c'est un
couvre-feu strict le maire de la ville
vitali klitschko a déclaré que tous
civils qui seraient dans les rues
pourrait être considéré comme un ennemi
potentiel